you factor here but we don't know what
the full effect will be of everything
that we saw and I want to hear thoughts
from people in the audience I want to
thank everybody who has of course
participated in the live stream on
Twitch and everywhere else we are
getting back up and running on YouTube
as well as on Facebook and it is just
going to take me a moment to get all of
that stuff going and working correctly
but it is all going to happen don't you
worry let's see here we are almost all
set
welcome back to everybody who has been I
guess watching the debate elsewhere or
and maybe not watching it at all at I
guess I don't know what people have been
doing but we are now back on all of the
different platforms and I think we are
going to be able to put our let's see
here we will be able to put our Super
chats back up on the screen and I think
we will not be losing anything either so
I think we're in good shape here yeah
I'm feeling I'm feeling pretty good
about it I don't know about anybody else
okay so what do we have going on here it
seems that a lot of stage management is
going on Michael Bloomberg has sort of
has you wandered into the crowd it's
hard to tell where Bloomberg is or he
can't possibly be thrilled with his
performance so very very difficult to
imagine that he's happy with how this
all went down Wow Wow
what what a debate what a day um the
Super chats are starting to come in with
opinions I'm just trying to figure out
what Michael Bloomberg is doing he does
seem to have kind of ambled in the
direction of the crowd I don't I just
don't fully understand what's going on I
do want to say thanks to Michael Connery
who is new member number 27 of the
evening thanks Michael I really do
appreciate your support let me know in
the chat who do you think did well who
do you think did not do well I certainly
do not believe that Michael Bloomberg
had a good night trying to see if Bernie
is maybe going to talk to him always
interesting to see what dynamics develop
after
michael bloomberg certainly sort of kind
of just hanging a much much longer than
everybody else and I quite frankly don't
know what to make of it shaking hands
with people I don't know if this is
Michael Bloomberg's wife maybe or I just
I just don't know who that is but
Bloomberg engaging in dialogue I think
is maybe what we call it ok let me see
what's on people's minds via super chat
here is they're starting to come in Mac
says Chuck's question about delegates
versus popularity was telling yes indeed
Taylor Neil side II says did they skip
Bloomberg's closing statement no they
they didn't know we we we saw the the
Bloomberg closing statement right or did
you know now that you mention it I don't
remember a word he said did they skip
him what no he was second right he went
second yeah yeah it was just so not
memorable
that what he said is blending into his
last question for me Praveen Govindan
sends a super chat Shawn Geiss whoops
sorry about that folks
Shawn Geiss says I'm fuming over the
ending when everyone but Bernie said the
majority with delegates shouldn't be the
nominee openly against democracy
unbelievable yeah they're playing a game
they're playing the game saying there is
a process and the process should be
followed even if it hands the nomination
to somebody else who didn't get a
plurality of the of the delegates David
Hill says Chuck Todd made it was
Republican framing on all questions on
many not all and Keegan Smith says can
you play clips for people who didn't
watch we will have clips on tomorrow's
show there's no simple way for me to
grab the clips I would want right now so
that is unfortunately not something not
something that I am able to do in the
immediate let me say thank you to Jen
Williams Jen Williams is new member
number 28 at join pakman.com we do have
a coupon code that is a 66 percent off
coupon code and I will welcome and thank
everybody who signs up at join
pakman.com regardless of whether they
use the coupon code or
over on Twitch Noah Andelman has grabbed
a twitch Prime subscription LD hunter
has grabbed the prior twitch Prime
subscription new Midian Nomad has
subscribed for six months Jared keish
has subscribed for two months ramekin
beast has subscribed and euphoria io o
and iconic one as well let's see here
Kevin de Lu says that anyone did you
notice amy trembling and almost crying
yeah I mean at every debate she has the
quivering voice I don't know if she has
vocal dysphonia Bobby Kennedy jr. has
that vocal condition I don't know if amy
has it when you google it it doesn't
come up but it sounds like it and she
does always seem like she's almost in
tears I think it's just her delivery
thanks to Kunal Singh for the super chat
Erin Robbins has sent a super chat but
has issued a retraction of the message
dumbass loser says I subscribe to your
site three times tonight okay I didn't
see anyone's name come through three
times that's interesting
but yeah I appreciate it dumbass loser
which is an unusual name Annika Patil
says how do you think how do you rank
the candidates performances and the
effects this will have on the Nevada
caucus
I think Bloomberg did the worst
essentially and beyond that Bernie was
strong Biden was the strongest he's been
if Biden had brought this level of
energy from day one he might not have
completely torpedoed his campaign
Salomon carpenter says surprise pete
resisted the urge to ask bloomberg for a
campaign contribution oh I'm sure that
they'll get to that that will come later
Brandon oh hold on sorry Brandon the
fish says it's funny
because they would all say Hillary
should have won in 2016 when she didn't
get a majority Sheehan says Dems can't
complain about electoral college if they
support convention super-delegates
hypocrites you either support the
popular vote or you don't not a crazy
analysis Christian Gordon says what was
the deal with those people interrupting
Biden
during his closing statement I don't
know I mean they were protesters of some
kind I couldn't understand what they
were saying if anybody understood what
they were saying I'd be interested to
hear about it Junie McGraw says this
debate was like professional wrestling
very entertaining but not very
informative or productive I think Bernie
won overall though yeah I agreed and in
fact I tweeted and I I'm not asking for
your vote but I would love your retweet
I tweeted a little while ago Oh Kim
dot-com followed me on Twitter how about
that I tweeted a little while ago that
this is a very entertaining debate but I
don't know that we're learning that much
and that maybe this is part of the
problem and I tweeted some other clever
things - guys come on please this is my
please clap moment no I'm kidding I'm
Joseph van Scoy great to see you Joe I
don't understand why they don't endorse
nuclear energy we need every tool in the
toolbox to combat climate change small
modular reactors are the future of
energy I've said I am in favor I'm open
to nuclear as a bridge the problem is
once you bring on more nuclear you know
taking it offline when it's still
producing is easier said than done
easier said than done let's put it that
way how routine des Marion says did you
think Biden took adderall Biden was shot
out of a cannon during the first part
and then all of a sudden he was
lower-energy Biden again I don't know if
it was bolstered with some kind of
pharmaceuticals it's a good question
Green Ranger says Bernie and Chuck Todd
were talking at the end
odd Chris cannon says am I alone in
thinking Pete's debate style is
off-putting
I find Pete's debate style off-putting
as well Chaka Berry says there are
hundreds of Blumberg signs in Milwaukee
interesting Phillip Waller says how much
do you think this will hurt Bloomberg
love your show by the way it has to hurt
Bloomberg right I have a poll right now
on my Twitter account if you follow me
at D Pakman you will see I have a poll
asking what will happen to Bert
Bloomberg's support after this and I
would love for you to vote and see what
what will maybe do the results on
tomorrow's show let's see here
dumbass loser says I subscribed three
times tonight as John ya couch honest
but I am a quadruple subscriber very
nice John I appreciate that so much and
I did see I did see a subscription from
you come through I want to say thanks to
Brendan Whitney who is new member number
29 this evening and I also want to say
thank you to Stephanie hazard certainly
not hazardous to get a david pakman.com
subscription very much appreciate that
and i believe i'm otherwise up to date
on all subscriptions there Kowalski from
Nebraska says Bloomberg lost everyone
else stayed the same
I like how Warren just set fire to
Bloomberg to open the night great
hashtag Medicare for all hashtag Bernie
bros hashtag real soy boys yeah if I had
to say what was my favorite cartoonish
moment it was when it was when Elizabeth
Warren at the first opportunity used the
term horseface lesbians and of course it
was co-opting alleged statements by
Michael Bloomberg but when you think
about how will how is Warren going going
to open you don't typically assume that
she's going to open with horse-faced
lesbians and phat broads I think what's
the other one and it was just brutal
brutal brutal on Michael Bloomberg the
entire night unbelievable Johnny black
storm says I hope the Trump uh black ins
feel the Bern 2020 let's see who Nieto
Rivera with a super chat Nick Newcomb
says what percentage of Warren's attacks
on Bloomberg would you contribute to
altruism would I attribute altruism
probably 25% I mean listen it's not
Warren's fault almost everything that
happens in these debates is is at least
slightly not genuine Lauder eight says
please speak with destiny I don't know
that I'm gonna talk tonight to Stephan
Kenneth destiny bunnell the second we
talk regularly and I don't right now
I'm just gonna do my own thing and then
we're uh we're just gonna rap because
we've got a big big day tomorrow
this is Katy tour by the way reporting
Donald Trump allegedly referred to Katy
tours transgender mom in some of the
most horrible horrible terms that you
can imagine really really ugly stuff and
you can check out my youtube channel for
info on that epic fails says was it me
or did blue me get some very loud cheers
I didn't notice that the cheering was
particularly loud for Bloomberg ghost
Reaper says my grandfather who watches
Fox as Bernie is corrupt because of his
wife I have no clue what he's talking
about
oh yeah there may have been some kind of
campaign finance probe related to Jane
Sanders but yeah I mean it's you know if
that turns your dad off from Bernie how
has he not abandoned Trump given all of
trumps corruption it's pretty wild
parrot Erin from Sweden I may get to
Sweden this summer Paris says hi friends
David could you make a schedule for your
live shows on your page we know we can't
they're often decided on pretty
last-minute PS is Cornel West on the
list on interviews I could watch eight
hours straight of you talking alright
that would be interesting to talk to
Cornell sure raka Barry says Bloomberg
is hiring Canvassers in Milwaukee they
pay six grand a month
Milwaukee's very poor I'm concerned yeah
Bloomberg's Bloomberg is paying staffers
very well it's not just Milwaukee where
they pay well
Jordon Worthington says who what are the
prospects of a TDPS Network they are low
because I don't want to do it I used to
have this idea of building out a network
and then I realized I'd rather just grow
this show I have just more control over
it and it's yeah well I I abandoned the
network idea a little while ago because
I realized I wanted to focus in other
ways is the way I would say it let me
say thank you to Eva Martin who is new
member number 31 tonight at join
pakman.com the coupon code saves you 66
percent we had a brawl at the studio
where we came to fish
the cuffs were my entire staff
surrounded me and said you can't do the
66% off you can't it's too much you
can't do it and I single-handedly
defeated everybody and created a 66
percent off coupon code so don't make
all of that fighting that I did a waste
take advantage of that coupon code 20 20
now at join pakman.com let me read some
messages from twitch let's see iha
chaloo has signed up with twitch prime
Jala hippo subscribed and says is there
any candidate whose drop out an
endorsement of Burnie would push his
lead over the edge where you would not
expect a brokered convention even before
Super Tuesday I mean to be honest any of
the top three have the potential to do
that and remember you can get 50 percent
of the delegates without 50% of the vote
because of the viability threshold I
explained this on the show today so yeah
I mean there's probably no based on the
current polling if you look at roughly
15% like if Biden or Bloomberg dropped
out and said go to Bernie right away it
could potentially push push Bernie over
the over the edge
let's see here a user who goes by the
name poop King says how do you feel CNN
treated Bernie this time well the debate
was on MSNBC so I think I don't know
what CNN has been doing but let me know
the wine cave spelunker says via super
chat was it me or did all the moderators
take each other out oh sorry the
moderates did the moderates take each
other out Warren definitely went down
swinging Bernie seems pretty much on
skates there was more intra moderate
brutality in today's debate for sure
poka lova says destiny sucks don't talk
to him okay surâqa Barry says I love you
good night love you too I've been told
that it's a faux pas when I don't say
love you too when any any viewer says
that they love me so love you too
Conner's
6:23 says if Bloomberg doesn't drop hard
after both this debate and his negative
media coverage recently then we need to
reevaluate the huge power of ad buys for
sure
Landon at Saverio says do you think yang
will endorse a candidate before a
nominee is chosen will it matter I don't
think he will and even if he did I don't
think it would make a difference he only
had like 2 percent support Kunal Singh
says did Trump drain the swamp his staff
says opposite no Trump filled the swamp
Zachary Munro asks would you consider
getting an app developed for the show
for all the livestreams content and
anything related to the DP show I would
consider that absolutely I would
AC zero five one zero says Trump had his
rally at 7:00 tonight in Arizona who got
more Arizona views lol yeah Trump seems
to do this with every debate recently
Rudy Mendoza says I'm a right winger I
respect your perspective thank you so
much Rudy I appreciate your support as
well all right we have a very early day
tomorrow so we are going to end our
coverage right now thank you for joining
me make sure you're following me on
whatever platform you've watched more
streams more shows more clips all of
that stuff I will probably send some
errant profanity-laced tweets tonight so
if you want anything else from me
tonight